tours en tout cas militant ou pas chacun
tente aujourd'hui de reprendre ses
esprits à commencer par les jeunes très
mobilisés vous le savez ces dernières
semaines après les défilés dans la rue
ou bien sur le terrain que reste-t-il
donc de ces mobilisation conséquente
alors pour tenter de le comprendre et
bien hélène pdg philippe renoir sont
allés poussé aujourd'hui deux portes
celles les jeunes socialistes rennais et
seul décès les étudiants de l'institut
d'études politiques à rennes les
premiers vous allez voir sont encore un
petit peu sonné quant au second et bien
ils sont plutôt heureux de la justesse
de leur combat difficile ce matin de ne
pas évoquer les résultats du second tour
dans ce cours de droit constitutionnel
pour ces étudiants en sciences
politiques leur analyse offre un
exercice grandeur nature entre les
couvre le sujet dans toutes les
conversations avec un maître mot face
aux 18 % réalisé par jean marie le pen
soulagement c'est un soulagement mais un
soulagement
personnellement je suis très contente
le rouge c'est un hommage les étudiants
de sciences po sont de ceux qui se sont
le plus mobilisés entre les deux tours
en manifestant bien sûr mais aussi en
allant discuter avec des électeurs
aujourd'hui ils se disent plutôt fier de
ses quinze jours d'action même si
certains reconnaissent avoir douté un
moment du port surtout la semaine
dernière que les manifestations et plus
martyrisé le pen et y avait des plus
mobiliser les gens pour voter pour lui
de côté je pense que faire quand même ça
quand même réveillé pas mal de gens ça
fait plus je pense que ça a surtout joué
au niveau de l'abstention qui ont baissé
et j'ai montré mon désaccord j'ai montré
d'une façon au dessus par la
manifestation colérique et hystérique et
je pense qu'on a organisé quelque chose
d'intelligent et de d'absolument pas
moralisateur surtout au mouvement des
jeunes socialistes non plus on n'a pas
ménagé sa peine pour faire front aux
candidats fn
et pourtant ce matin les militants se
sont réveillés avec un drôle de
sentiment un peu groggy ça pendant
quinze jours on a peu dans le feu de
l'action à se mobiliser à organiser des
manifestations certaines mobilisations
donc
donc c'est vrai que hier il a fallu mais
des bulletins chirac dans l'urne
donc il a fallu prendre ses
responsabilités et puis regarder la
réalité en face la réalité c'est la
démission de lionel jospin du poste de
premier ministre aussitôt remplacé par
jean pierre raffarin et pour les jeunes
socialistes
ça change tout à partir de maintenant on
sait ce revenu sur l'affrontement
classique toujours structuré le débat
politique l'affrontement entre la gauche
et la droite et je pense que je préfère
cet affrontement la queue l'affronterons
entre la droite et l'extrême menthe
on a un peu de mal à trouver notre place
pour eux le nouvel élan est tout trouvé
dans la perspective des législatives dès
cette semaine ils arpenteront marché
campus universitaire pour défendre leurs
couleurs